[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne gellineck guten Abend der
weihnachtliche Frieden in der Ampel
scheint wiederhergestellt zumindest
vorerst nach rund 200 Stunden
Verhandlungen präsentierten Kanzler
Vizekanzler und Finanzminister den
Kompromiss der das Gerüst für den
Haushalt 2024 bilden soll was genau
beschlossen wurde ist noch nicht in
allen Details ausgearbeitet bei der
Pressekonferenz am Mittag stellte jede
Partei zunächst heraus wo sie nicht wird
sparen müssen die SPD bei den
Sozialleistungen die Grünen bei
Heizungstausch und wirtschaftsumbau und
die FDP bekommt eine wieder geltende
Schuldenbremse als Trophäe vorerst über
den Tag in Berlin berichtet Thomas
Reichard an diesem Morgen werden ein
paar Dinge klarer im Kanzleramt die
Fenster und die Sache mit dem Haushalt
nur ein paar Stunden Schlaf liegen
hinter Scholz Harbeck und Lindner als
sie vormittags zurückkehren nach einer
letzten verhandlungsnacht nach Wochen
haben sie sich endlich geeinigt und ein
erleichterter Finanzminister versucht es
gar mit einem Witz im Kabinett sei es
eben um eine Strategie gegen Einsamkeit
gegangen ich kann allerdings feststellen
dass wir drei in den letzten Wochen
nicht betroffen gewesen sind wir haben
intensiv gearbeitet und wir können hier
heute vor sie treten mit dem klaren
Signal diese Koalition ist handlungs und
einigungsfähig auch bei sehr schwierigen
Aufgaben 60 Milliarden Euro fehlten der
Koalition nach dem Karlsruher Urteil
plötzlich dennoch so Kanzler schz die
Ampel halte fest an ihren
klar ist aber wir müssen mit deutlich
weniger Geld auskommen um diese Ziele zu
erreichen priorisieren heißt deshalb
miteinander zu klären was wir uns
leisten
können und was nicht fragen dazu wir der
Kanzler erstmal nicht beantworten und
sein Blick zurück scheint zu sagen dass
auch sonst niemand auf die Idee kommen
solle eigentlich müsste Scholz jetzt
direkt in den Bundestag aber es
dauert geh davon aus dass der Kanzler
hoffentlich gleich
pünktlich zu seiner Regierungserklärung
erscheint tut er dann tatsächlich die
Lösung für das Milliardenloch die er
dabei hat heißt vor allem sparen weniger
Steuererhöhungen und auch die
Schuldenbremse wird nicht einfach
ausgesetzt mit dieser Einschränkung klar
ist aber
auch sollte sich die Situation durch
russlandskrieg gegen die Ukraine
verschärfen etwa weil die Lage an der
Front sich verschlechtert weil andere
Unterstützer ihrer ukrainehilfe
zurückfahren weil die Bedrohung für
Deutschland Europa weiter zunimmt dann
werden wir darauf reagieren müssen bei
Friedrich märz wird es dann lebhaft im
Plenum die Union sprach schon vom
möglichen Bruch der Ampel von Neuwahlen
empörte Zwischenrufe deshalb aus der SPD
Fraktion und ein ebenso empörter März
der Scholz wegen der Ukraine eine neue
trickerei beim Haushalt vorwirft sie
wissen dass sie das nicht einhalten
können was sie heute morgen hier gesagt
haben es ist eine vorhersehbare Notlage
die sie spätestens zur Mitte des Jahres
erklären werden müssen und dann wollen
sie uns in Anspruch nehmen noch einmal
für die Überschreitung der
verschuldunggrenze des Grundgesetzes
diesen Trick lassen wir Ihnen nicht
durchgehen Herr Bundeskanzler später
sitzen die ampelspitzen noch mal
zusammen im Kanzleramt beim
milliardenkompromiss hat jeder das
Gesicht gewahrt die SPD beim sozialen
die Grünen beim Klimaschutz die FDP bei
der Schuldenbremse nur der Streit mit
der Union um diesen Haushalt der wird
wohl
weitergehen wie gesagt noch sind nicht
alle Beschlüsse aus der Nacht genau
ausbuchstabiert aber klar ist dass die
Kürzungen und Sparvorschläge dieses Mal
uns alle betreffen Strom Sprit und das
Heizen werden teurer Inlandflüge auch
Andreas Huppert mit einer ersten Analyse
der
Streichliste was haben
Plastikverpackungen mit dem
Bundeshaushalt zu tun bisher eher wenig
in Zukunft allerdings viel mehr denn die
von der EU eingeführte plastikabgabe
immerhin 1,4 Milliarden pro Jahr wird
künftig nicht mehr vom Bund beglichen
sondern von den Herstellern und dem
Handel Konsequenz des neuen
Sparhaushalts dass die plastikabgabe von
den in verkehrbringern gezahlt wird die
stimmt technisch aber am Ende werden wir
sie in den kundenpreisen wiederfinden
teurer wird auch in der Land Wirtschaft
denn die deutschen Bauern müssen künftig
ebenfalls mehr an den Staat abführen der
vergünstigte Agrardiesel für die Land
und Forstwirtschaft fällt weg und bringt
die Bauern auf die Barrikaden wir sind
darauf angewiesen können ohne Diesel
keine Lebensmittel für die Bevölkerung
erzeugen und mit diesen Vorschlägen
würden wir ins Mark getroffen werden
mehr Einnahmen für den stat auch durch
einen höheren CO2 Preis eigentlich
sollte die Tonne Kohlendioxid ab Januar
40 € Kosten jetzt geht's rauf auf 45 das
wirkt sich beim Autofahren aus denn der
ab 2024 schon höhere Spritpreis steigt
dadurch laut ADAC beim Benzin noch
einmal um 1,4 Cent Diesel wird damit um
1,6 Cent pro Liter teurer die Förderung
von E-Autos lässt die Bundesregierung
früher als geplant auslaufen das spart
und Steuern drauf heißt es beim
innerdeutschen Flugverkehr eine
Kerosinsteuer soll hier die
Staatseinnahmen steigern geeinigt hat
man sich auf 1,5 Milliarden Euro
Einsparungen beim et des Arbeits und
Sozialministeriums z.B in dem
ukrainische geflüchtete schneller in
Arbeit gebracht werden die
Sozialverbände fürchten allerdings
Kürzungen im allgemeinen man will
einerseits besser vermitteln mehr
Menschen vermitteln braucht dazu
eigentlich mehr Personal und
gleichzeitig wenn man hier den rohstift
ansetzen das passt alles nicht mit
anderen Worten wir haben mehr
Fragezeichen nach dieser Pressekonferenz
als vorher klein klein statt großem Wurf
so bewertenliche Ökonomen den
Sparhaushalt letztlich ist es eine
Mogelpackung es ist man hat das Problem
in die Zukunft verschoben man hat hier
keine dauerhafte Lösung für die
fehlenden 60 Milliarden Euro gefunden
und
auch keine Antwort darauf was man
wirklich tut um zukünftig mehr
Investition tätigen zu können die
politische Einigung steht das letzte
Wort hat jetzt das Parlament spätestens
im Februar soll dann der Haushalt 2024
endgültig beschlossen werden
es hagelt Kritik an den Beschlüssen der
Ampel darüber wollen wir reden mit
Robert habbeck Vizekanzler und Minister
für Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz guten
Abend nach Berlin hallo guten Abend sie
haben heute Mittag in Berlin den
bemerkenswerten Satz gesagt das tut mir
weh was an diesem Paket das Sie heute
beschlossen haben schmerzt sie am
meisten ach da will ich jetzt gar nicht
unterscheiden aber es ist natürlich
immer klar gewesen dass wenn wir nicht
Probleme die ja entstanden sind durch
die Situation in Europa also g Krieg der
den Russland gegen die Ukraine führt und
durch die Wirtschafts und
energiepolitischen Krisen danach nicht
mehr durch Kredite heilen können wie das
jetzt ja verwrt ist dass wir entweder
Gelder einsammeln müssen also mehr Geld
generieren müssen oder Programmtitel
streichen müssen und das haben wir jetzt
getan und das ist ja auch eine Zumutung
für bestimmte Teile der Bevölkerung oder
für bestimmte Wirtschaftssektoren das
ist nicht schön und ich verstehe den
Unmut aber es ist natürlich die einzig
denkbare Antwort und wir haben uns
entschieden möglichst breit einzelne
Maßnahmen zu machen deswegen hat es auch
so lange gedauert statt ganze Sektoren
oder ganze
Bevölkerungsgruppen in einem großen
Umfang zu betreffen tut's nicht aber
auch ein bisschen weh dass sie bei der
Förderung von Solarenergie kürzen
mussten aber nicht bei der reduzierten
Steuer auf Diesel denn die Kritik an
dies Haushalt ist ja dass die Maßnahmen
nicht mutig genug sind dass es kein
Neustart ist sondern irgendwie ein
weiteres durchvorstellen reicht ihn das
oder war einfach nicht mehr möglich also
so so nehme ich es nicht wahr die Kritik
die ich wahrnehme ist ein breiter Chor
an Kritik an jeweils einzelnen Maßnahmen
und gerade bei den wo Verbräuche teurer
werden also wir werden ja jetzt eine
Subventionierung der chemischen
Industrie die bisher vom Staat getragen
wird die sogenannte plastikabgabe
einführen sass also am Ende die
Verbraucher und die Verbraucher für
Plastikprodukte das sind werden nur
centbetriäegge sein aber es werden eben
Centbeträge sein einen Beitrag zahlen
müssen das nehme ich wahr und wenn sie
nach dem Diesel Fragen also mit der
höheren CO2 Abgabe wir kehren ja auf den
fahr der großen Koalition zurück also
das was die Regierung Merkel beschlossen
hat wird jetzt wieder Realität wird auch
das Tanken teurer moderat sind
Centbeträge pro Liter aber auch das wird
teurer insofern glaube ich es so wie ich
es warnehme die Kritik nicht ähm ihr tut
zu wenig sondern alle die jeweils in
bestimmten Bereichen Plastik oder CO2
Abgabe betroffen sind sagen hätte das
denn nicht auch anders gehen können
genau also der CO2 Preis sie haben es
gesagt er steigt von jetzt 30 € auf 45 €
ab 1 Januar pro Tonne CO2 dadurch wird
tanken und heizen teurer außerdem
streigt der steigt der Strompreis und
haben sie das durchgerecht rechnet was
das für die Bürger heißt und über einen
Ausgleich nachgedacht das ist natürlich
sehr unterschiedlich wie viel gefahren
wird oder beruflich gefahren wird da
gibt es ja die pendlerpuschale die wir
damals angehoben haben als die
Energiepreise für das Tanken so hoch
waren im Jahr 22 die ein Großteil dessen
noch abfedern werden aber es ist richtig
nicht mehr die alle Kosten die die Krise
ausgelöst hat können übernommen werden
bei den Netzentgelten ist es so dass
durch die hohen in Energiepreise des
letzten Jahres die waren nicht mehr ganz
so hoch wie 22 aber immer noch höher als
im Normalfall wegen der höheren
Gaspreise die Netzentgelte so teuer
geworden sind wir wollten die übernehmen
wir hatten dafür einen Fond wir hatten
das schon als Gesetz fertig gemacht und
im Grunde schon beschlossen aber dann
wurde dieser Fond nach dem Urteil von
Karlsruhe aufgelöst und wir haben keine
weiteren
Refinanzierungsmöglichkeiten gefunden
die auch noch zu übernehmen es wäre noch
mal 5üninhalb Milliarden gewesen dafür
gab es dann keine Möglichkeit mithr die
uns eingefallen wäre ohne weitere
Belastung an anderen Stellen wo wir sie
nicht haben wollten auszulösen genau und
das müssen jetzt die Verbraucher zahlen
wie glauben sie wird das bei den Wählern
ankommen die ja im Moment sowieso nicht
riesen Fans der Ampelkoalition
sind wenn man keine Schulden mehr
aufnehmen darf und man sich politisch
vereinbart hat keine Steuern zu erhöhen
dann gibt es ja eigentlich nur noch zwei
denklogische Konsequenzen entweder der
Staat übernimmt weniger Leistung also
federt nicht mehr alle Kosten ab die ja
aus dem System heraus entstehen sind da
keine Kosten die durch den Krieg den wir
uns ausgedacht haben sondern sie kommen
von außen die hohen Energiepreise kamen
von außen und dann haben wir sie
versucht abzufedern mit Schulden mit
Krediten das geht jetzt nicht mehr nach
dem Urteil oder wir müssen mehr
Einnahmen machen wir haben jetzt beides
getan wir haben Subventionen gestrichen
also mehrinnahmen für den Staat
organisiert aber wir können auch nicht
mehr alle en übernehmen das ist die
Konsequenz in der politischen Realität
in der wir sind natürlich verstehe ich
dass das Leute darüber nicht fröhlich
sind wer will schon gerne mehr Geld
bezahlen aber es war immer klar also mir
war das vom Tag ein an klar nach dem
Urteil was das bedeutet und das darf ich
noch mal sagen dass es nicht verwechselt
wird es hat an dieser Stelle nichts mit
dem Klima und transformationsfond zu tun
also der Unterstützung der Wirtschaft da
haben wir unsere Probleme selbst gelöst
ja ist ist sogar so das kann ich noch
dazufügen dass wir in dem Klima und
transformationsfond die EEG Umlage
beibehalten also wie die übernehmen wir
die als Staat wir sorgen also dafür dass
Verbraucher und Verbraucher beim
Strompreis auch entlastet werden das hat
man daran hat man sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon gewöhnt aber
trotzdem ist es nicht nur alles bastung
sondern wir verteidigen auch die
Entlastung okay kommen wir noch mal
zurück zur Schuldenbremse das ist ja so
ein bisschen etikettenschwendel denn sie
lassen sich ja zwei Hintertürchen offen
einmal bei der Hilfe für die Flutopfer
und einmal bei der Hilfe für die Ukraine
ähm warum sagen Sie nicht einfach Leute
wir schaffen es nicht ohne
Schulden ich sehe es anders es ist kein
Etikettenschwindel sondern ganz im
Gegenteil wir übernehmen ja jetzt durch
die jetzt eben andiskutierten Maßnahmen
Kosten die durch den ukrainekrieg
ausgelöst sind wir unterstützen die
Ukraine mit 8 Milliarden Militärhilfe
also kaufen Waffen für Sie wir haben
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine in
Deutschland was ungefähr kosten von 6
Milliarden verursacht und dann gibt es
noch
Aufbauposition all das finanzieren wir
nicht über Kredite und Schulden weil man
jetzt auch ein Zeichen setzen wollte
dass wir diesen einfachen bequemen Weg
nach dem Urteil nicht erneut gehen
sondern finanzieren es aus dem Haushalt
es ist also gerade nicht der billige Weg
die Schuldenbremse zu
überspielen das einzige was der
Bundeskanzler gesagt hat und ich sage
das gleiche ist wenn die Ukraine weitere
Hilfe braucht weil es an der Front
schwierig wird weil das Land sich mehr
verteidigen muss weil Russland mehr
drohen schickt wenn wir also noch mehr
tun müssen dann wird es nicht gelingen
über noch höhere bepreisungen von
bestimmten Verbräuchen diese
diese Ausgaben zu stemmen und das finde
ich auch korrekt und richtig und das ist
meine Ansicht nach auch völlig in Rahmen
mit dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts wenn eine noch
größere not entsteht dann wird man auch
darüber nachdenken müssen die Notlage
wieder auszurufen allerletzte Frage nach
diesem haushaltsmarathon und
durchverhandelten Nächten was hält die
Ampel noch zusammen außer dem Willen zur
Macht nein aber das ist doch ein Beweis
wie handlungsfähig wir sind wir sind
alle über unseren Schatten gesprungen
niemand hat dir sein lieblings oder
Parteiprogramm durchgesetzt hat lange
gedauert das liegt daran dass wir uns
viel intensive Debatte gegönnt haben um
die richtigen Entscheidungen zu treffen
aber es zeigt doch dass wir in der Lage
sind schwierige ich meine was gibt's
denn für Politiker unpopulärere Sachen
als Belastung für die Bevölkerung zu
beschließen und das tragen wir gemeinsam
keiner stielt sich aus der Verantwortung
und deswegen ist das eher ein Tag der
noch mal zeigt was diese Regierung
leisten kann sagt Robert habbeck
Vizekanzler und Wirtschaftsminister
vielen Dank für das Gespräch und einen
guten Abend nach Berlin danke
schön das Gespräch haben wir am Abend
aufgezeichnet und in unserem heute
journal Update um 0:45 Uhr gibt's noch
eine Reaktion der Opposition dort ist
Thorsten frei im Interview der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der CDU
CSU Fraktion im Bundestag
und auch bei unserem nächsten Thema
brauchte es quälende Nachtsitzung und
zähe Verhandlungen um einen Kompromiss
zu finden von dem ebenfalls noch nicht
ganz klar ist was er bedeutet die
Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai ging heute
zu Ende mit einem Abschlussdokument das
Raum für Interpretation lässt von einem
Ausstieg aus den fossilen Energien ist
nicht mehr die Rede wohl aber von einer
Abkehr Andreas Stamm und Elisa Miebach
Berichten aus
Dubai der hammerfeld keine einwendee
mehr zugelassen nach einem finalen
36stündigen Verhandlungsmarathon
hektischer pendeldiplomatie zwischen den
rund 200 Staaten steht das
Abschlussdokument mit Kompromissen die
nicht leicht fielen so die
Außenministerin diese Klimakonferenz
besiegelt de facto das Ende des fossilen
Zeitalters sicher nicht an jeder Stelle
des Textes so klar und verbindlich wie
wir uns als Europäer das an allen
Stellen gewünscht hätten ein Umstieg ist
es geworden eine Abkehr mit
Einschränkungen mehr war mit den Erdöl
förördernden Ländern nicht zu machen
schwierig finden wir dass dieser
Ausstieg aus den fossilen Energie noch
eine Menge Schlupflöcher enthält
darunter die Betonung der Rolle von Gas
als
Übergangslösung das ist letztenendes ein
Freifahrtschein für die fossile
Energieindustrie und auch die Öl und Gas
förörderländer das macht die Einhaltung
der wichtigen 1 5 Grad Grenzen natürlich
noch mal schwieriger immerhin
beschlossen wurde die Energiegewinnung
aus erneuerbaren bis 2030 möglichst zu
verdreifachen Wind Sonne und Co könnten
dann die fossilen mehr und mehr
verdrängen viel zu tun auch für
Deutschland auch in anderen
Bereichen ganz klar ist dass in
Deutschland jetzt in dieser Dekade auch
geguckt werden muss auf den
Gebäudesektor auf den Mobilitätssektor
wo wir noch großen Rückstand haben auf
das was erreicht werden muss damit wir
unsere Klimaschutzziele erreichen können
sie wollten das Ende von Öl Gas und
Kohle nun ist es eher der Anfang vom
Ende geworden für die Aktivisten zu
wenig für die Staatengemeinschaft das
was maximal möglich
war fragen wir nach bei unserem
klimareporter Andreas Stamm in Dubai
Andreas der Aufruf sich von den fossilen
Energien wegz beewegen steht im
Abschlusspapier jetzt drin ist das ein
Fortschritt oder ein
Rückschritt
also es ist definitiv ein Fortschritt
denn bislang hat man um das Thema Öl und
Gas in diesen abschlussdokumenten ein
großen Bogen gemacht jetzt steht's drin
es ist nicht der erwartete harte
Ausstieg es ist ein Umstieg aber das ist
eben eine Richtung die es vorgegeben und
viele sagen die ist jetzt unumkehrbar
dann muss man auch nicht verachten das
verdreifachen der erneuerbaren Energien
das heißt eben dass man hier einen Boom
auslösen will und dass man ja die
fossilen dann mehr oder weniger
verdrängen kann und dass auch neue
Investitionen in Öl und Gas sich einfach
nicht mehr rechnen ist das schnell genug
nein keines fallalls die Wissenschaft
ist eindeutig mit diesen ja mit diesen
Maßnahmen hier wird man es nicht
schaffen die globale Erderwärmung auf
1,5° zu begrenzen das wird sehr sehr
schwierig das ist wohl nicht möglich und
es gibt eben diese großen Schlupflöcher
für Länder wie Saudi-Arabien Kuwait
Katar also die ölfördernden Staaten und
das kann eben dazu führen dass die den
denken wir können erstmal so
weitermachen und müssen nichts ändern
also es geht in die richtige Richtung
aber eben nur in vielen kleinen und
kleinsten Schritten und die müssen noch
einen großen Schritt ergeben das war
Dubai nicht Andreas Stamm war das der
für uns die Klimakonferenz beobachtet
hat vielen Dank nach
Dubai und hier geht's jetzt weiter mit
den Nachrichten und Heinz Wolf und die
beginnen mit einer umstrittenen
Auszahlung von EU-Geldern ja die
EU-Kommission hat gut 10 Milliarden Euro
an Ungarn freigegeben das Geld war
bislang blockiert weil Ungarn
rechtsstaatsmängel vorgeworfen wurden
inzwischen seien die verlangten
Maßnahmen für die Unabhängigkeit der
Justiz umgesetzt worden so die
Kommission und sie betont dass es keine
politische Entscheidung sei mit Blick
auf die bislang ablehnende Haltung von
Ungarns Ministerpräsident Orban zu
ukrainehilfen und Beitrittsverhandlungen
darüber soll ab morgen auf einem
EU-Gipfel beraten
werden der ukrainische Präsident
selenski hat Viktor Orban heute
aufgefordert seine Haltung zu einer
EU-Mitgliedschaft klarzustellen bei
einem Besuch in Norwegen sagte selenski
er habe Orban vor kurzem bei einem
direkten Gespräch gesagt dass dieser
keinerlei Grund für eine Blockade habe
die ukrainische Hauptstadt Kiev war in
der vergangene Nacht wieder schweren
russischen Raketenangriffen ausgesetzt
nach ukrainischen Angaben wurden mehr
als 50 Menschen verletzt zwar seinen die
Raketen von der Flugabwehr abgeschossen
worden aber herabfallende trümme hätten
Gebäud getroffen es gab schwere Schäden
und Brände
über engere Beziehungen der EU mit den
sogenannten
westbalkanländern wurde heute bei einem
Spitzentreffen in Brüssel beraten es
nahmen Vertreter aus Albanien Bosnien
herzegowiina Serbien dem Kosovo
Montenegro und nordmazedonien Teil in
einer Abschlusserklärung wird auch auf
die veränderte Sicherheitslage verwiesen
und wie wichtig deshalb hier eine
strategische Partnerschaft sei
in Polen ist Donald Tusk nach der
Bestätigung seiner Regierungskoalition
durch das Parlament als neuer
Ministerpräsident vereidigt worden am
Vormittag legte er im Warschauer
Präsidentenpalast vor Präsident duda den
amtseit ab damit ist der
Regierungswechsel vollzogen Tusk steht
für einen klar proeuropäischen Kurs
bereits am Nachmittag reiste er nach
Brüssel wo er morgen am EU-Gipfel
teilnehmen
wird Israel hat die Forderung der UN
Vollversammlung nach einer sofortigen
humanitären Waffenruhe im Gazastreifen
zurückgewiesen Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu sagte sein Land werde den
Krieg auch angesichts internationalen
Drucks bis zur Zerstörung der Hamas
fortführen gestern Abend hatte die UN
Vollversammlung mit großer Mehrheit eine
rechtlich nicht bindende Resolution für
eine sofortige Waffenruhe im
Gazastreifen verabschiedet 153 Länder
stimmten dafür zehn dagegen 23 Länder
enthielten sich darunter auch
Deutschland es klingt wie ein
spionageroman aus dem Kalten Krieg ein
bnd-agent und ein deutsch-russischer
Geschäftsmann lernen sich in München
kennen und Arbeiten erst zusammen für
den BND später dann auch für den
russischen Geheimdienst FSB pickant das
ganze passiert während des ukrainekriegs
als es dem BND gerade gelungen war die
Chats der russischen Söldnergruppe
Wagner mitzulesen der Verrat der
Doppelagenten vereitelte die Überwachung
jetzt stehen beide vor Gericht Sarah
Tacke
berichtet was Sie als nächstes planen im
ukrainekrieg das sollen die Söldner der
Gruppe Wagner in einem geheimen Chat
ausgetauscht haben und diesen geheimen
kriegschat soll der BND mitgelesen haben
noch im Sommer vor einem Jahr bis er BND
Mitarbeiter Carsten l den Russen
Dokumente zugespielt hat haben soll die
zeigen dass der geheime russische
kriegschat vom BND gehackt wurde 450 000
€ soll Carsten l dafür bekommen haben
Arthur e Diamantenhändler in Russland
geboren soll der Kurier gewesen sein für
400.000 € Soller geheime BND Information
zum russischen FSB gebracht haben der
General buundesanwalt geht davon aus
dass es sich um zweif Fälle des
landesvahrats in besonders schweren
Fällen handelt und zwar weil ein
besonders schwerer Nachteil für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gedroht habe
durch diese Taten und da sieht das
Gesetz dann tatsächlich eine lebenslange
Freiheitsstrafe vor oder Freiheitsstrafe
nicht unter 5 Jahren auf der Anklagebank
nehmen cararsten l und sein mutmaßlicher
komplizer Artur e heute erstplatz als
die Kameras den Saal verlassen haben ein
außergewöhnliches Verfahren sagt auch
der exagent und langjährige BND
Mitarbeiter Gerhard
Konrad Vorwürfe sind selten in ihrer
Schwere solche verratsfälle passieren
auch hoffentlich natürlich nur sehr
selten insofern dass jemand ein
Innentäter tatsächlich hochgeschützte
Materialien es waren zwar relativ wenige
aber sehr bedeutsame weiter giibt darf
nicht passieren aufgeflogen ist der
mutmaßliche farat schon nach kurzer Zeit
durch eine Warnung befreundeter
Geheimdienste was bedeutet das für den
BND ein größter anzunehmender
sicherheitsunfall dass jemand eben dem
man eigentlich vertraut hat der auch
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen erfolgreicher
überstanden hatte nicht der ja schon
seit Jahren um nicht zu sagen seit
anderthalb Jahrzehnten wenn ich richtig
erinnere auch ordentliche Arbeit
geleistet hat und irgendwann ist der
abgewandert
innerlich ja das hat er selber gemacht
ob Ksten l vom BND Mitarbeiter zum
Verräter wurde und ob er gemeinsam mit
Arthur e Sicherheits relevante
Informationen an Russland verkauft hat
genau das wird jetzt hier an mehr als 50
Verhandlungstagen geklärt 30
Sekunden und hier geht's weiter mit
Nachrichten aus Sport und Wirtschaft mit
Heinz Wolf die US Notenbank Fett hat auf
ihrer letzten zinssetzung in diesem Jahr
Zinssitzung in diesem Jahr den Leitzins
unverändert gelassen und sich am Abend
zur Entwicklung von Wirtschaft und
Inflation geäußert Valerie hallle wie
sieht die Fett die Lage sie sieht sie so
dass Sie davon ausgeht dass im kommenden
Jahr Zinssenkungen wieder möglich sind
stärkere sogar als bisher angedeutet
drei stellt fettchef Paul 2024 in
Aussicht wann klar das ließ er offen die
notenbänker gehen davon aus dass sich
die Inflation in den USA weiter
abschwächt und dem angestrebten 2% Ziel
annähert die Fed rechnet damit dass die
US-Wirtschaft zuletzt an Schwung
verloren hat im kommenden Jahr jedoch
weiter wächst an der Wall Street hatte
man vor allem ein Ohr für die vermutlich
anstehenden Zinssenkungen die
Begeisterung groß der Dow Jones so hoch
wie nie der DAX hegen ist leicht unter
seinem jüngsten Rekordhoch geblieben die
Einigung der Ampel auf einen
Bundeshaushalt schmeckte viel nicht viel
sparen kaum Investitionen so das viel
gehörte Votum Anleger gehen davon aus
dass die Fett spätestens im Mai die
Zinsen wieder senken wird wenn es in
Europa soweit ist darauf könnte es
morgen eine Antwort geben wenn die EZB
ihren nächsten Zinsentscheid trifft zwar
dürfte niemand von einem Zinsschritt
ausgehen aber wenigstens von hinweisen
wo die Reise hingeht mit schnellen
Zinssenkungen ist jedoch nicht zu
rechnen Valerie Haller vielen
Dank keine Medaille für beide
Weltmeisterschaft für die deutschen
Handballerinnen die Chance darauf
machten heute im Viertelfinale die
schwedinen zu nichte sie gewannen
27:20 gegen das deutsche Team und jetzt
die Zahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewehr 10 11 22 27
31 39 die super Zahl 1 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdfde und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 das war's von uns für heute hier
geht's weiter mit dem Sportstudio und
der UEFA Champions League und um 045 Uhr
meldet sich dann nasan gökte mir mit
unserem heute schnal Update Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend und bis morgen
tschüss wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eins ist schon mal
klar das Jahr 2023 wird das wärmste Jahr
im Vergleich zur vorindustriellen Zeit
die Temperaturabweichung liegt bei
1,46° ja und seit Juni sind alle Monate
global gesehen rekordmonate und auch der
November man sieht hier eindeutig die
roten oder die rötlichen Flächen
überwiegen hier die blauen Flächen sind
in der Minderzahl schauen wir auf Europa
und da verabschieden sich die Tiefs
allmählich hoher Luftdruck macht sich
breit aber es gibt noch etwas Regen und
Schnee vor allem im Süden Deutschlands
an den Alpen Regen und Schnee wandern
allmählich südwärts und auch im
Erzgebirge in den höheren Lagen fät
Schnee im Norden gibt's zaghafte
Auflockerungen und die tiefsten
Temperaturen liegen bei -1° Richtung
Schleswig-Holstein und im Osten und es
kann örtig glatt werden in den höheren
Lagen sowieso dann wegen des Schnees am
mildesten bleibt es noch mit 7° im
Südwesten ja morgen dann weiterer Regen
und Schnee in der Mitte und das wandert
langsam Richtung Süden an den Alpen
setzt Dauerschneefall ein bis Freitag
ansonsten von Norden her lockert es auf
die Sonne zeigt sich hier bleibt es
überwiegend trocken bei Temperaturen von
2° ganz im Norden und 9° im Südwesten es
ist schon mal kühler als heute und die
nächsten Tage am Freitag gibt's Regen
und Schnee wandert in den Süden lässt
nach im Norden gibt etwas Sonne bei 2
bis 8° und das Wochenende wird mit 2 bis
10° milder ruhiger und etwas sonniger
schönen
Abend